こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
僕、前このー、フィルムケースを使って
あの、外で・・・・・・・
へぇぇっくしょいっ！（くしゃみ）
ロケットを作ったんですけど、
・・・その、
今日はですね、
前回ロケットは、こう・・・
な・・・手作業で、
手作業で全部入れて
一気に爆破させてやろうとか言ったけど
失敗したんすよ！
あれはもう大失敗！
やっぱりドクターはじめとしては、
あんな失敗許されないんですよ
なので今回はですね、
へへっ・・・
ちょっと無数のフィルムロケットを準備したんで
こんな感じです
今回はちゃんと考えました
一応このフィルムロケット全部に
一応お湯を入れる、と。
お湯の方が反応しやすいって聞いたので、
お湯を入れて、
ロケット用入浴剤も全部準備してあるんで、
このフタの裏に入浴剤を付けて、
テープでとめて、
こうすると・・・。((カチッ
・・・でもまだ反応してませんよね
お湯と入浴剤がくっついていないんで、
まだ反応してないんです
この状態で、
まだ反応してない時にこうして・・・
ひっくり返す・・・。
そしたら、全部、一気に反応するんじゃねーか・・・
・・・ってね！
僕はね、もう、
失敗した時からずっと考えていたんですけどもぉ！
・・・・・・・・・・ただロケットを飛ばす・・・
ってか家じゃん ココ！
でもただロケットを飛ばすんじゃ面白くないんで、
この一斉に飛んでくるロケットを
俺はね、もうね、
動体視力がマジでもう、スーパーヒーロー級なので
全部素手でキャッチしてね、
みんなにドヤ顔で自慢したいと思います
・・・じゃ 準備！
フィルムのこのフタに
入浴剤をセットして・・・
テープで・・・とめます！
で、あとはここにお湯を入れて、
こうして、
一応設置完了、ということで。
お湯の準備しなきゃ
((カチッ
うぇーい
しっかりこういう感じでとまります
あぁ、怖い・・・。
怖い怖い怖い
《早送り中・・・。》
うおぉぉぉーし！
ここまで上手くいきすぎて怖いんですけれども、
ねえ、これほんとに大丈夫？
上手くいくかなぁ？
これ失敗したら俺・・・泣くぞ
じゃあ今からこの発射台を・・・
被せて！
もうここは俺の腕だな
被せてもう、グルッと回して、
全部一気に発火させて
それを全部手でキャッチします！
ねえ大丈夫？ほんとに？
ヤバくね?
ってか、てか、俺ん家大丈夫かな？
いや、そういうのどーでもいい！
これがな？
ロケットっていうものはな、
夢を叶えるために・・・やるしかないんだ
・・・ちょっと、録画されてる？
スリー、ツー、ワン・・・
FIRE！
うわ、これほんと一発勝負だわ
FIRE!とか言いながら怖くてできない・・・
よし、設置・・・セット完了！
あぁ怖い・・・これ失敗許されへんもん
頑張れはじめ、
お前に日本の世界の未来がかかっている！
おりゃぁぁぁっ！
おりゃぁぁぁっ！（2回目）
んー、ちょっとミスったこれ
ちょっとミスった
いや、大丈夫だ、なんとか
よし、行くぞ、取るぞ！お前ら！
ヤバい・・・うわー、これちょっとマジかよ？！
めっちゃこぼれてね？なんか
うわっ！
《はじめしゃちょー格闘中・・・》
うわぁぁ！痛ぇぇっ！！
うわぁっ！
あっはあっはああっはぁ・・・（泣）
なんなのぉ・・・（泣）
ぬあぁっ！
無理！痛い！痛い！
痛いよ？！
もう無理無理　ほんとちょっと待って待って・・・
ちょっと待って・・・
ちょっと待って（2回目）
ちょっと・・・
ちょっと待って・・・
もう！もう大丈夫だよね？
ビックリしたぁ！
１個も取れなかったっす・・・。
けどなんか・・・
うわぁっ！ちょっとぉっほぉ・・・（泣）
なんかね、
なんか自分の
可能性というか・・・
なんか・・・
たのっ・・・
とれっる、とれ、取ろうと思えば取れました、でも。
けどちょっと・・・
ビビり過ぎて・・・
もう大丈夫だよね？
もう大丈夫・・・だよね
もう来ないよね？
もう無理なんだけど、
なんか何も信じられない、もう・・・
もうこないよね？
え、ほんとに？
もう大丈夫？マジ・・・
いやいや、本気で
いや、ちょ、なんかさー、
触った瞬間飛ぶとかほんとやめてね
そういうの一番無理だから
あ、
うわぁっ！・・・もぉぉぉ～（泣）